a group of young men who left london for
syria and committed crimes which have
pulled the world
their faces were always hidden behind
masks so their hostages identified them
by voice called them the beatles because
of their british accents
the ringleader known as jihadi john was
killed in an airstrike another reached a
plea deal now el shafiel sheikh found
guilty of all the charges against him of
kidnapping westerners who went to syria
to do good subjecting them to random and
regular beatings routine humiliation and
brutal death
aid worker kayla mullow was 25 when she
was captured in syria her remains have
never been
found her father and boyfriend were in
court
it's a little bit of justice and
uh we're glad for that we we know that
this this guy's not gonna hurt anybody
anymore and
um
it's
i don't think you get close closure you
just learn how to deal with it
journalist steven sotloff's execution
was recorded and released by the beatles
as propaganda stephen's dad art fought
to bring his killers to justice
how was it being in that court so close
to
one of the men who was
involved in the awful things that
stephen went through
well
you start to find in yourself
restraint
because i think all of us would have
liked to jump over the
little bower there and you know do
something to him but
you know um
the reason he's here is because he
wanted to make sure that he got a fair
and honest trial
do you feel like
any sense of justice has been found
in this process
yes
i feel and i felt
that all our kids are in that room with
us
looking down
because the justice is for them
nobody else
thousands of miles from the syrian
desert where they committed such
appalling acts the monsters behind their
masks exposed their guilt confirmed in a
u.s court martha kellner sky news
virginia